Oh receives a new series of arrests in
Hong Kong is adding to concerns that
governments are using coronavirus fears
to crack down on human rights the u.s.
is criticizing China after police
detained leaders of Hong Kong's protest
movement Holly Williams reports fifteen
of Hong Kong's pro-democracy leaders
were arrested in a single day they
joined with millions of other Hong Kong
as last year demanding that China give
them full democracy one of those taken
by police was Jimmy Lai a wealthy
newspaper owner we interviewed him for
60 minutes at the height of the
demonstrations in October if we don't
fight we will lose everything
what do you mean lose everything well
when you lose their freedom he lose
everything democracy movement nip it in
the bud Keith Rich berg is a professor
of journalism at Hong Kong University
and told us the virus provided an
opportunity for a crackdown the virus
has really gotten people off the streets
I think that's probably given a window
for the government to go out start
arresting people protest movements
around the world from Baghdad
anti-corruption demonstrations to grete
tone Berg's school strikes have been
effectively silenced by the virus
meanwhile special emergency powers mean
Hungary's Prime Minister can now rule by
decree indefinitely and Thailand's
leaders can censor and shut down media
the arrival of coronavirus was
authoritarian 3 gives them an excuse to
ban political rallies it gives them an
excuse to kind of crack down on the
media the question is whether when this
crisis is over citizens will be able to
regain the freedoms they've lost for CBS
this morning Holly Williams